Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
¿Alguna vez predijeron algo que les iba
a ocurrir en sus vidas y no les pasó?
Yo hace muchos años, cuando era chica,
estaba re-segura de que
me iba a dedicar a la actuación.
Y estoy acá en un escenario,
pero soy politóloga.
Y en la facultad,
me enseñaron que en algún momento
el capitalismo se iba a autodestruir
por su propia fuerza, y no pasó.
Y también me contaron que
más o menos para esta época
íbamos a estar en el fin de
las ideologías, y creo que tampoco.
Hasta un hecho tan importante
para la historia
como la caída del muro de Berlín
no pudo ser anticipado.
Es que las predicciones en la política
y en las vidas a veces la pifian.
Hace muchos años cuando
nos imaginábamos que la tecnología
iba a transformar
radicalmente a la política
se decía que el voto por Internet
iba a ser universal en 2030.
Parecía que los cambios en la forma
de gobernarnos iban a venir por ahí.
Es más, cuando yo tuve que decidir
mi tema de tesis de doctorado
decidí estudiar el voto electrónico.
Era un tema de tesis raro
porque la ciencia política
siempre se ocupa del presente,
o del pasado reciente.
Pero a mí lo que me desvelaba
del futuro de la política era eso,
era cómo el voto electrónico
lo iba a hacer.
O eso creía.
En ese momento se decía,
y muchos proyectaban,
que íbamos a votar en 2030
en pijamas desde nuestras casas.
Y que le voto electrónico
con unas máquinas parecidas
a los cajeros automáticos
como esta iba a ser la antesala
del voto por Internet.
Y yo la miro y pienso
que muy probablemente
esta predicción también la va a pifiar.
Porque ya hoy en 2019,
cada vez hay menos países
que usan voto electrónico.
La política está cambiando.
Sí, pero no de la forma
en que imaginábamos.
Yo sigo convencida de que entender
el futuro de la política es clave.
Y junto a varios colegas argentinos
y de otros países
estamos tratando de entender
cómo va a ser el 2030,
cómo nos vamos a gobernar.
Déjenme contarles algunas cosas
sobre las que tenemos algunas certezas
de cómo va a ser el 2030,
y seguro van a transformar a la política.
En 2030, la inteligencia artificial
aplicada a los procesos de todo tipo
--de producción, de servicios--
va a haber transformado
a las economías desarrolladas.
Y muy probablemente va a haber
agrandado la brecha, la distancia,
con los países en desarrollo
como la Argentina,
si no se adapta a los cambios
que vienen.
También sabemos y lo vemos venir,
lamentablemente,
que vamos a estar sufriendo
los efectos del calentamiento global.
Y muy probablemente para 2030
el centro del poder económico mundial
va a haber girado a Asia.
China probablemente
va a haber reemplazado a EE.UU.
como el centro del mundo económico.
Y Europa va a ser
una región menos poderosa.
Pocos ponen en duda estas megatendencias.
Y eso quiere decir que el motor de cambio
no va a ser solamente la tecnología,
que siempre acapara la atención.
Y es cierto, la cuarta revolución
industrial como le llaman algunos,
seguro va a cambiar la forma de gestionar.
No sé, tendemos asesores
políticos que sean robots.
También seguro va a cambiar
la forma en que nos relacionamos
con nuestros representantes.
Y ya lo estamos viendo y nos sorprende.
Por ejemplo, cuando el presidente Trump
comunica su política exterior así,
en un tuit.
Y eso nos trae problemas
que antes no teníamos.
Porque la legislación de EE.UU.
no pide que guardemos estos tuits.
Pero sí nos pide que guardemos
los discursos de Trump
cuando va al Congreso.
Y también hay cambios que nos preocupan
porque están llegando antes
de que nos podamos ocupar de ellos.
Piensen, por ejemplo, cómo están
cambiando las campañas electorales.
Y hoy nuestras leyes
se volvieron obsoletas.
Regulan cuánto se gasta en la televisión,
cuánto se gasta en la radio,
pero no dicen nada de cómo se usa Facebook
o WhatsApp para informar
o para desinformar a los votantes.
Pero la transformación
más profunda de la política
no va a estar en la tecnología.
El cambio va a pasar por quiénes
van a tomar decisiones
en un mundo tan distinto,
y sobre qué asunto
las vamos a poder tomar.
Para imaginarnos cómo
se va a gobernar el 2030
tenemos que pensar cómo van a ser dos
de sus protagonistas centrales:
los gobiernos y las empresas.
Y ahí les tengo que decir que
tenemos más incógnitas que certezas.
¿Dónde se van a tomar las decisiones?
¿Será en las ciudades, en las naciones,
que cada vez están más encerradas
sobre sus fronteras?
¿O será en las instituciones globales?
En las que creamos
después de la Segunda Guerra,
como las Naciones Unidas.
O, no sé, las que vayamos a crear.
Hoy los nacionalismos están en auge.
Y cada vez más hay desconfianza
en esas instituciones globales
que creamos.
Es más, lo vemos
por ejemplo en el Brexit.
Los líderes políticos cada vez
privilegian más las identidades locales.
Pero también estamos viendo que
los problemas son cada vez más globales.
Y no hay un solo país
que los pueda solucionar.
Piensen, por ejemplo,
cómo protegemos la privacidad
de nuestros datos en Internet.
Hay muchas voces hoy diciendo
que esas instituciones globales
tienen que tener más fuerza,
tienen que tener un rol más importante.
¿Cómo serán entonces las decisiones?
¿Más locales o más globales?
El problema es que los países
hoy son muy grandes
para los problemas pequeños,
pero muy pequeños
para los problemas grandes.
Esa es la primera incógnita.
La segunda incógnita es cómo
van a ser las empresas del futuro.
¿Vamos a vivir en un mundo
de pymes muy especializadas?
¿O en un mundo de grandes empresas
que ostenten mucho del poder
económico global?
Nos entusiasmamos con que
la tecnología va a bajar los costos,
que íbamos a tener un mercado
cada vez más disperso,
más descentralizado.
Pero hoy los gigantes de la tecnología
-- Amazon, Google, Facebook --
cada vez están más concentrados.
Y no sabemos cómo van a ser
las empresas del futuro.
Y esa es la segunda incógnita.
Si cruzamos esas dos dimensiones
podemos pensar
distintos mundos donde vamos a vivir.
Muy distintos.
Cuatro mundos para el 2030.
Y los invito a que nos asomemos
juntos al futuro de la política.
En un extremo, podríamos vivir en un mundo
dominado por grandes empresas
bajo un gobierno global.
No sé, una especie de parlamento mundial,
una nueva versión de las Naciones Unidas.
A ese mundo lo llamamos
"Mi buen amigo el gigante".
¿Se acuerdan? Como el cuento
de Dahl que se llevó al cine.
En este mundo seguro podemos
tener alguna posibilidad
de encontrarle una solución al cambio
climático, o a algún problema global.
Pero seguramente en este mundo
nos sintamos muy lejos
de las decisiones que se toman
en los centros de poder global.
Quizás algún algoritmo ayude a que
tomen en cuenta nuestras preferencias.
Pero sería muy distinto a hoy.
Y eso sí,
en este mundo necesitamos
unos líderes políticos muy capaces.
Tienen que llevar a cabo un doble juego.
Tienen que negociar con las
grandes empresas y tomar decisiones
que nos rijan a todos
los ciudadanos del mundo.
¿Estamos formando
a esos líderes políticos?
Y ahora los invito a viajar
al mundo opuesto.
También posible.
Un mundo donde hay muchas
pequeñas empresas,
pymes muy especializadas,
con gobiernos locales.
A este mundo nos gusta llamarlo
"Lo pequeño es hermoso".
Pero no estoy tan segura
de que vaya a ser tan hermoso.
Acá la innovación tecnológica
va a ser más lenta.
Y no va a ser posible seguramente
que le encontremos alguna solución
al cambio climático.
Va a ser muy difícil coordinar
las acciones entre tantos actores.
Eso sí, seguramente nos sintamos
más partícipes de las decisiones.
Y hay otros dos mundos posibles más.
Un mundo de unos pocos pie grandes
del sector privado
conviven con muchos gobiernos más pequeños
-- no sé, quizá les suena familiar --
En este mundo,
las grandes empresas que operan
más allá de límites territoriales
resisten las decisiones
de gobiernos más pequeños.
Y hay un cuarto mundo, también posible.
Quizás el menos probable,
en el cual vivimos en un ecosistema
de pequeñas empresas
que compiten bajo una autoridad global
En cada uno de estos
cuatro mundos las decisiones
se van a tomar de manera muy distinta.
Y seguramente tenga un impacto
muy distinto en la democracia,
que hoy está siendo cuestionada
en muchos lados y muy distintos
-- Italia, Brasil, India --
Es que las frustraciones con la política
provocan mucha bronca con las dirigencias.
Y hoy aparecen fenómenos nuevos.
Quizá lo vieron hace
unas semanas en Ucrania
un cómico que actuaba
de presidente en una serie
se convirtió en presidente.
Lo eligieron de presidente
de verdad en las urnas.
A veces la política supera a la ficción.
Cualquier análisis que hagamos,
cualquier combinación de estos escenarios
seguramente va a darnos un mundo distinto.
Y nos abre muchas preguntas.
¿Queremos un parlamento mundial
que se ocupe,
por ejemplo, de regular
la inteligencia artificial?
¿Creemos que puede convivir
un parlamento mundial
con gobiernos más pequeños
que se ocupen de los problemas
más chicos, más locales?
¿Hay un sistema distinto
a la democracia que vayamos a inventar?
¿Va a ser el régimen
más extendido del mundo?
¿O el giro a Asia hará que
tengamos más autoritarismos?
¿O crearemos una nueva
forma de gobernarnos?
Todas esas preguntas nos las hacemos
porque el futuro de la política
no está escrito aún.
Y seguramente cuando hagamos
estas predicciones
la pifiemos, como con el voto electrónico.
Pero trazar esos escenarios
y poder imaginarnos
cuál es el que nos parece más deseable,
mejor para la Argentina, es un juego.
Es un juego divertido, predecimos.
Pero también es un acto
de responsabilidad.
Porque lo que vaya a ocurrir
allá en el 2030
va a tener mucho que ver
con lo que hagamos hoy,
con los cambios que emprendamos hoy,
con cómo formemos
a los próximos dirigentes,
y con cómo anticipemos
los dilemas del futuro.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)